we're in the the overarching topic of
probability probably how likely is
something to happen over nothing what's
the what's the chance okay now we've
looked this before and we keep coming
back to this fundamental idea because
simple as it is it's full of very deep
insights right we say probability we
mean it's a fraction it's a comparison
between two quantities something over
something the things are on the
numerator favorable outcomes you know
the ones that you're interested in the
ones that you want divided by the sample
space or all the total things that
didn't happen
okay now one of the things that we have
discovered is that often part of the
trick of the question is just being able
to work out what these are but they're
complicated but once you get that like
all you have to do is you know multiply
there are things I simplify easy enough
okay so one of the most common things
that we get is that you don't for
example your sample space meters I
select 10 socks in a row that's a sample
space right and the order of those socks
it matters because I want there to be
pairs in there right so selecting things
in a certain order is kind of half the
problem of working out probabilities of
different things okay and there's a
whole bunch of important things just
about ordered selections not to do with
probability at all okay so what you'll
find is as we're looking at it over the
next couple of exercises right that
beyond the language of where's the
chance was the probability will sort of
recede into the background for a little
while it'll go sort of on the back
burner and instead you'll hear you don't
know the phraseology of how many ways
right so we're not working out fractions
anymore we're gonna be working out
numbers big numbers right like if dude
isn't all that kind of thing okay by the
way ordered selections that's a bit of a
mouthful mathematicians tried to make it
a little better but they didn't succeed
very well the other fancy name for this
is permutations okay how many ways are
there to select from a bunch of
different things when you're interested
in the order and we call those
permutations
okay so you might recognize that way now
let's look at a simple example
okay how many permutations are there on
example a four-digit p.m. a four-digit
pin right because you know if you've got
bank card or if you've got a phone that
you can't the security about you're
gonna have a four-digit pin right well
how many different ways how many from
permutations can you get of this thing
okay well let's think about it like this
Pyrrhus what about my four digit PIN is
going to go okay
in fact that's that's what my screen
even whoops I turn it on it's like look
you're gonna have to type in four
characters okay now you then think about
what's going to go in each of these
slots right now if I say four digit like
let's let's stick with numbers you know
if you go to the other shops in the F
post machine it's just got numbers on it
really
how many options have I got to put into
you know you're you're making a password
into this first spot over here hmm now I
cut the options as 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
right so I have 10 options right so I
can put 10 different things in that spot
cool now when everybody to the next spot
right so this is like a multi-stage
event if you like I've got another 10
options I don't have to worry about you
know with or without replacement
anything I'm just picking a number
that's all ok so I've got another tense
different options another easy right so
being that I have to pick all 4 and they
all combine together remember it's a
multi-stage event but this is all
happening simultaneously it's one event
so what do I do with these numbers which
rule do I use this is the product rule
isn't it is all of these characters
events happen at the same time to make
my four-digit pin so I multiply them I
get 10 times 10 times 10 so there are 10
through the 4 different combinations and
you can see very easily how this could
turn into a probability question right
for instance if I randomly
got your folding tray and guess your
password what is the probability that I
guess the right password and the answer
is you know one in 10,000 I'm not very
good chances right but there you go you
can see how this question feeds into
this question make sense okay so if you
want to catch it in the the language
that we've already been using okay this
thing here is with replacement with
replacement because I had the same bunch
of numbers and I keep on putting it back
okay so this is okay now I know it's a
little bit contrived but let's replay
the scenario I still want afford it to
be okay but let's suppose you know I'm
bit of a I know that repeated digits are
actually a bad idea in a password they
are so I say look I want to not have any
repeated digits as I go through okay so
when I have a look at this first one
I've got all ten to pick from yeah I can
still pick any of zero different fashion
enemy so far so good
but then when I pick the next one I
don't want to pick from the same number
so if you like this is without
replacement right so how many options do
I have left for the next number it's a
nine and then once I pick two well there
are eight left and then for the last one
there will be seven left yes just like
before all of these things are happening
simultaneously so again I use the
product rule I multiply right now how
can we write this how practice obviously
I can write it as just ten times nine
times eight times seven but we have
language that would make this a little
more concise right when you're
multiplying and you're decreasing by one
the language that we use is factorial
notation right so this clearly looks
like 10 factorial at least it starts
that way but it doesn't end that way
does it and we looked at this under
binomial right I'm missing when I'm
missing off the end a missing six
factorial right so you don't you don't
subtracted though you're dividing by C
factorial okay now I'll push like this a
little further
clearly that six factorial is not just
some random I just pick out six
what is it six and not seven or three
what is that six come from it comes from
the fact that I've used for the options
right so that's why they are a six
factorial left over here but I have it
included right so it's 10 factorial on
10 - 4 factorial that's really where the
numbers come from and you can see it's
built at the same time this as this
right the 10 as in how many digits they
were and the 4 sorry 10 how many
different numbers you got too small and
for how many digits where they were
that's how we built this number of
permutations okay so this is replacement
okay so let's generalize a little bit if
I have okay if I have n objects in
objects for instance if I have 10
numbers 0 what did you find in oil okay
and I have K positions to put them into
okay but n objects and I want to put
them into K position okay then in this
case how many permutations are there
well it'll be n times n times n times n
however many times you have positions
right K times so that would be n to the
power of K with replacement okay
obviously you could expand this out to
say you know what if it wasn't numbers
what if we allow letters in there as
well and then I guess you would have
your ten digits in your 26 letters and
you would say well it'd be 36 to the
power of 4 obviously many more options
right okay now when you come down to
here it's a little more complicated but
it's still the same numbers it's still
the same numbers you're still gonna have
n factorial to start with but you're not
going to have n factorial by the end
unless you're picking that many
positions
about K positions so this would be n by
this K factorial right now this comes up
so much and it's sort of awkward to put
into your calculator repeatedly that
your calculator has a special button for
this we say it's n P okay and it's right
next to it some important cousin which
you're familiar with can walk through it
and see K we'll come back to this guy in
future times because I know you're
familiar with him but it comes up in
this context a little differently okay
so I think it's a shift what what is it
above is it about like plus or minus or
something x plus x so you've got P for
ya it's above it's above x it's P for
permutations really but just in in in
normal language you either say NPK or
you say n pick pink okay right because I
want to pick out K of them I want to
pick out four of them right and I've got
em to choose from
does that kind of make sense and this
scenario like before digit pin it comes
up again and again and again you've got
20 horses in a race how many different
tractors are there 20 horses in a race
20 horses right is this with or without
replacement it's a trifecta its trifecta
is first second and third place right
clearly that's without replacement
because you can't get the same horse
coming first and second and third unless
it's some kind of weird weird quantum
Schrodinger's horse or something I don't
anyway so you got 22 strong it's without
replacements this scenario right so
you're going to pick three 20 peak three
by the way what is 23 I assume it's a
very large number 6840
right so if there's a 20 horse race and
you're betting right and the trifecta is
a female you bet on right if you don't
know anything and you pick out a
trifecta random right which by the way
if you go if people go to the TB and
they'll just press like a random
generator because I'm on who knows right
well that means you've got a one in 6840
chance on getting the trifecta I think
I'd rather go wash your car and ask for
$10 if I want to earn money but anyhow
each to his own so does that make sense
you've got these two ways of approaching
permutations based on whether you're
replacing or not